bonjour et aujourd'hui nouvelle épisode
Le Pen semble avoir hésité entre bonjour
belle fin d'après-midi et bonne soirée
résultats et la balancé les trois en
même temps
677ème journal de bord bonsoir
Jean-Marie Le Pen bonjour
le FN il a pas celui qui l'a inventé le
mouvement Jean-Marie Le Pen oui je le
regrette pour quelle raison les gens le
regrettent parce que il est comme vous
le dites et il en a été le fondateur si
j'écoute ce que je dis Véronique on ne
peut pas avoir d'amitié homme-femme bah
si bien sûr
habiter à la maison avec son mari donc
après des choses
merci beaucoup Bruno goniche vient de
nous dire qu'il regrettait que le
fondateur du FN Jean-Marie Le Pen n'est
pas été conviée
il peut regretter Bruno bien sûr
c'est un choix d'ailleurs qu'il aurait
souhaité venir tout à fait honnête je
crois que l'odeur sur le plateau ne
laisse et ben voilà Patrick a trouvé le
sourire des kefta ce soir enfin bonne
émission
pendant une heure et 6 minutes il va
carrément dérouler un programme alors
Bertrand se bat pourquoi l'ordre la
laïcité l'immigration le travail la
santé l'éducation le logement transport
culture aussi l'écologie le pauvre
anxiété tellement gentil me fait de la
peine le mec il est à son 50e échec de
la semaine
j'ai bien l'impression que dans cet
aventure il est devenu plaquiste parce
qu'il se prend vraiment une tonne de mur
donc cause reconvertir en maçon ce
serait beaucoup plus logique pour lui je
vous le dis très simplement si la Nation
toute entière arrive à tenir cet
objectif qui est purement volontariste
faut pas décrire de loi de choses
compliquées si on se mobilise tous pour
le tenir
dans les pires scénarios on passe
l'hiver
franchement je vais vous dire une chose
dans les Philippines
qu'est-ce que vous appelez un enfant
Emmanuel Macron et un enfant oui il est
pas fini oh faut pas dire ça
non d'abord il existe plus c'est ça
c'était pour Babette je sais que je suis
là mais je voulais tester Babette
oui oui
donc cette phrase qui est vulgaire
disons-le qui renvoie même à quelque
chose de cette phrase vous allez me le
dire j'ai entendu Brigitte devant moi
lui dire soyez pas enfantin oui mais
c'est pas la même chose que la deuxième
phrase
comme un enfant alors disons l'esprit
d'enfance oui alors je retire pour vous
la phrase que vous avez dit qui est
vulgaire
du ghetto Daniel obono et Sandrine
Rousseau voilà c'est à 20h la chronique
enchantée de Sandrine Rousseau nos
invités
vous faites Michel Galabru vous êtes
vous
êtes complètement plantés